is candace oh in shock we're about to
find out she's the host of candace and
we're very happy to have her on tonight
candace owens i just don't i don't want
you to be hysterical about this crime
thing okay
by the way i'm just asking can you get
taxpayers to build a
wall around your house and calling the
national guard to protect you
as cortez and the rest of the congress
did
i cannot unfortunately and i will tell
you i am live from d.c tonight tucker
and i have to tell you that miss aoc
led a protest in front of the white
house today about climate change she was
in a crowd of people maybe about 500
people it's 98 degrees
and our therapy must be working is my
point i mean i can't imagine
suddenly you're terrified to be around
groups of people the insurrection was so
bad and then you just host an
insurrection outside
of the white house um and so it's just
ridiculous so she's such an actress
but i do want to point this out because
i think it's so frustrating definitely
people outside of outside of dc are
looking at the situation and going
we all know what this is we all know
that aoc is a bad actress but do the
republicans know this they actually
recognize that aoc is actually doing a
very good job
because what her job is is to act and to
pretend and to distract
while they work the democrats are
working i've said this in this program
before and i will say it again in very
clear terms they are working to
federalize the police force the
democrats are working to federalize the
police force okay so what aoc is doing
right now
is making sure that people don't pay
attention to the crime and pay attention
to instead
the white supremacy boogeyman it's the
same thing we look at kamala harris
everyone's oh my gosh what's she doing
nothing at the border yes
nothing at the border is kamala harris's
job her job is to make sure there's an
influx of illegals coming in
the democrats are winning right now so
at the same time that we're mocking her
we have to recognize
that aoc is actually winning because
she's accomplishing what she's meant to
accomplish
get people focused on white supremacy
yeah people focus on the
insurrectionists while at the same time
they federalize the police force and
they change the fundamental demographics
of this country to make sure
that they can also simultaneously
federalize elections down the line
it's such a good point and it can't be
said often enough and
and i fall for it too she's so
infuriating and childish
that you just get caught up in the
details oh hysteria i'm in therapy
because the
insurrection and you you missed i missed
the point that you just made which is
of course you're meant to get caught up
in the details so you missed the big
picture
thank you for saying that absolutely
candace owens a very smart person
i appreciate it thank you hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else